[Music]
okay we are gonna go get started here
thank you all for coming out my name is
Alexander rose on the executive director
here long now and we're coming up on or
coming through halfway through our 2016
season here at the interval and as many
of you know from tonight all these talks
do sell out so that the best way always
to make sure that you get advance notice
about these tickets is by being a member
how many people are members here Wow
see that's how you get tickets as well
as our patron so thank you very much for
getting the patron tickets has really
helped this series work out and we are
now recording the series and thanks to
our sponsor ed Burtynsky the
photographer who's working on his movie
and throughout the scene he's also
sponsoring our live cast so thank you
very much I'm gonna have Stuart give an
introduction to Stan thank you yeah hi
I'm Stuart brand from the long now
foundation do I have sound can you hear
okay great we're good
next ten thousand years last ten
thousand years for a lot of people is
kind of a you know you grind your way
into that for science fiction writers
they're right at home with that kind of
thinking and particularly science
fiction writers like the one with us
tonight who have gone that far and
further into the future in that far and
further into the past and held them all
in their mind I first got onto Kim
Stanley Robinson that with with Amara
series and red Mars Green Mars blue Mars
is an amazing piece of work
he has been doing book after book
trilogy after trilogy and the next thing
that's interesting about science
Reiter's is when they do a lifetime of
that kind of writing and thinking then
you get some extra perspective that is
watching itself think long term and
watching its own mind change over the
decades of thinking that kind of
long-term so we have a 64 year old
science fiction writer here tonight and
I can't wait to hear what he has to say
Kim Stanley Robinson well thank you
Stuart and thank you everybody for
helping me and having me here I
we lost the title of the talk but it's
something like climate change will force
post capitalism or something like that
and that's the train of thought that I
want to pursue here and it will
hopefully orient me the the way I want
to start is to put the crisis in a kind
of quantitative terms that we can burn
about 500 gigatons more carbon into the
atmosphere
b-before we've hit the 1.5 seed average
global temperature rise beyond which
things get stranger and more dangerous
according to the scientists making the
guesses and that at the current speed of
burn will happen at about the year 2040
so the quicker we slow down the longer
we have before we hit that kind of a
moment but what has to be added to that
is that we have already discovered 2,500
Giga tons of fossil carbon in the ground
in the form of coal oil and natural gas
and those 2,500 gigatons of carbon are
already on the books of corporations as
assets and already claimed by
nation-states as national resources so I
once did a literally back of the
envelope type calculation to current
prices of carbon and this is in a very
artificial exercise for one thing the
current price of carbon is
since I made the calculation and I got
it either a hundred and sixty trillion
dollars or 1600 trillion dollars but you
know what's a decimal point among
friends it was a lot of money and they
were going to be people of goodwill who
in positions of power as a fiduciary
responsibility to their shareholders or
as a political duty to their citizens
are going to be wanting to burn some
portion of those trillions of dollars of
those gigatonnes thinking that will slip
a trillion or so into their coffers
before the clamp comes down and the the
whatever is left the two thousand
gigatonnes that needs to be left in the
ground so that we still have the same
planet iran now will be some kind of
stranded assets and stranded assets on
company's books create what you might
call zombie companies this is we call
them zombie banks in Japan if you have
supposed assets that are actually debts
or are stranded assets and you can't
tell how much they are and you don't
discharge them from the books then you
have a zombie Bank and this is going to
happen to some of the biggest companies
on earth in a system that is neoliberal
capitalism late capitalism postmodern
capitalism it's a world order a
combination of nation state laws and
international treaties that that governs
the entire world and as we spoke of
algorithms earlier in the introduction
there's a very simple algorithm
algorithm at the base of all there's
kind of like a prime directive or a
first axiom it like in Euclid that
everything else comes out of and this is
out of neoclassical economics which is
simply to assume that for human beings
more is better so when you start with
this prime directive that more is better
which is from Pareto and from and to a
certain extent from Adam Smith it
simplifies and in the economic textbooks
they will simply say this removes a
value considerations from economic
calculations which is of course
disregarding that more is better is a
value in itself but in any case more is
better equates to two measurements in
the algorithm that would be a quarterly
profit and shareholder value and when
these are the main criteria for whether
we're doing well or ill on this planet
you immediately get to some very serious
problems and sticking to carbon for just
a second here I'll say that it was the
president of the World Bank who
therefore is one of the high priests of
global capitalism who said we need to
put a price on carbon and this was a
astonishing admission for someone who is
a spokesperson for a free-market
capitalism and a neoliberalism to say
essentially the pricing system has
failed when it comes to putting a christ
on carbon and it's not the price we put
on it is too low the true cost of it is
higher than the price and it's an
admission of market failure from right
in the heart of the market system itself
now what's interesting about this notion
of under pricing is it's not just carbon
all commodities and all labour are under
priced and this is because of the way
our system works there's a downward
pressure on pricing because it's a
cumulative equilibrium
it's crowd sourced it's democratic it is
a indeed a cumulative equilibrium of all
the buyers and sellers coming together
agreeing and a free contractual manner
that I'll pay you this much for this and
such and I'll sell it to you for that
much unfortunately all the buyers are
stressed and want to buy things for as
little as they can get them so they buy
at first each of cheap as possible all
the sellers want to stay in business and
are in competition with other sellers
and so there is on both sides in a
collision of everybody alive today to
make prices shift downward to the point
where things cost things are priced for
less than it cost to make them and I get
confused with that because it sounds
like a description of
ripsi and indeed many companies do go
bankrupt but what happens is the true
cost which was higher than the price
that got charged and paid is shoveled
under the carpet and into the future
externalities for the biosphere and
labor costs that are below a living wage
for labour so what happens is that to to
parts of the world get hammered by this
drive downward of prices that the the
selling things for less than they cost
to make means that there's what this is
a technical term in economics called
dumping or even predatory dumping where
you sell things for less than cost to
make it hope to drive your competitors
out of business and then you raise the
price to the level where you make a
bigger profit but in this case the
competitors are future generations who
are very poor at competition at this
point so what this is also some
additional Ponzi scheme works and it
could be that now if you think of our
economy as a multi-generational Ponzi
scheme that now is them the Bernie
Madoff moment is now we're hitting it
and the that's why we see the
environmental and human problems that we
see there's a wonderful now one of the
ways that economics manages to excuse
itself for this predatory dumping on the
future it's the assumption that's made
in classical economics that the future
is going to be richer than the present
and that also if you rate our interests
against all of the future generations
which extend out maybe to well the long
now ten thousand years then we are don't
rate very highly rated to everybody else
so it gets some amortized the future
gets discounted so if you discount the
future at a 1% rate then you're saying
that the future is going to need our
help and we therefore are going to save
money and we're going to treat the
future as if it's important and needs
our help but if you think the future
because of our great technical
advancements they're going to be richer
than us you discount the future more
heavily like at a 5% rate saying look
they'll take care of themselves and so
so a small
discounting rate values the future a
high discount rate dis values the future
and there's always a very high
discounting of the future in our economy
and it has to be said that this is a
political and ethical decision it's not
a scientific technical or economic
decision except in as much as economic
decisions our political and ethical
decisions at all point so the future
pays for what we've done and the
assumption that is made in economics is
they'll be able to pay their way out of
it later has to do with fungibility the
idea that everything is fungible to
anything else and especially to money
itself that essentially if things would
go bad they will just pay money to buy
their way out of it but unfortunately
there are many things that are not
fungible to money health extinction
there are things that you can't buy your
way out of an ocean acidification we
can't buy our way out of and this is
just one of many things so the other
problem with the capitalist system that
we're living in we have now given the
name inequality and that's a good name
and it seems in the past they've called
it class or at times and it's had
different names but inequality calling
it now it's not a bad name for that what
we're talking about 1% of the people on
the planet own 42% of the human wealth
and the top 5% of income earners on this
planet of capital holders own about 85%
of the human wealth so it is a kind of
an Oleg Archy it's as extreme as it's
been since the Gilded Age or since
feudal times people have different ways
of raiding this but it is very very hard
people are noticing it an inequality
which is a natural result of the
capitalist system it's not people gaming
the system or cheating the system it is
the natural result of things working the
way they work you get a human population
where only one or 5% or maybe 20% of the
population is comfortable everybody else
the joke is to call it the prokaryote
you know from the proletariat to the
prokaryote everybody's situation is
precarious there's been a
financialization of risk
financialization of daily
if risk has been shifted off onto people
and now again this is an economic term
risk sort of implies like you're in a
casino that you get to choose if you say
well I don't like risk I'm going to
avoid risk and so I choose not to take
risks but the risks are of of aging of
getting sick of not having a pension in
other words these are not so much risks
as inevitability and the cost of them
have been privatized rather than
socialized in the last thirty years it's
also true that the richest and the
poorest people on the planet have the
worst impacts on the environment the
richest people by way of overconsumption
I mean we all consume 30 times the
resources of your ordinary peasant in
the Indian backcountry and and we are
not most of us in the 1% and so
consumption goes up from there and then
the idea of how many people there are on
the planet is not anywhere near the same
as thinking how many consumption units
are there on the planet which varies
according to affluence and then the
poorest by way of deforestation and
topsoil loss essentially if you need to
feed your family that night and you need
firewood to do it you go out into the
forest you cut them down you're not
worrying about anything else but getting
food on the table that night for hungry
people and then with the forest cut down
this topsoil runs away and you get a
vicious circle of environmental impact
so the upshot is that the system that
we're living in is destroying both
people in the biosphere and it's not an
accident well no it is an accident but
it's not a distortion of the system as
such it's the straightforward working of
the system as such as design so we're in
a bad algorithm and yet it is the law of
the world so at this point I think you
know it's justify all to be justifiable
to be concerned
maybe terrify it is the right word you
know if we have to save the environment
of the world from climate change and
then you add on to that well you can't
do it unless you save and reform
capitalism itself the law of the world
it's like doubling down and it would be
better if you could just
solve the environment first and then
solve our human problems but the problem
is the human problem is the
environmental problem the two of them
are connected the two of them are
intimately related and in fact the one
follows from the other so well I have
left myself half the time here to save
the world so I will proceed but I'll
have to go fast how do we fix this given
where we are and it's best to use Nepal
air Lakes iPad formula to articulate how
we're going to save the world our our
impact on the environment is it not just
a matter of human population but of
population times appetite or affluence
times technology this is the famous iPad
formula and it's very useful for
articulating this manner that human
being is not not all human beings have
the same impact on the environment so
let's take it one at a time you say
population we do need to stabilize
population and this is something that
often doesn't get allowed to be talked
about by the environmental movement cuz
it sounds like then you're more
interested in the environment than your
own people although the two are so much
the same but you can say that and have
immediately the solution because
population stabilizes when women have
their full set of legal rights and this
has just been proved demographically
thank you across the whole world we have
had sample cases in Thailand in
Indonesia and in the prosperous half of
Mexico when laws have changed they give
women their full set of legal rights and
education etc the population replacement
rate drops below 2.2 percent which is
the replacement 2.2 kids from per woman
it drops below that down into a
sustainable and even a decrease in
population this is something we can
count on and it means that there's a
double good you know women's rights
equal population stabilization equals
environmental stabilization it's a great
doubling it's not a doubling to complain
about or like oh my gosh we want this to
be a pure moral good without use value
you sell you and moral value together
that's not a bad thing to have it's just
empowers them both then secondly
technology I mean
holder's catalog cleantech we are
getting closer and better at clean tech
we've been in a sort of Stalinist che
lubinski 65 of a world way dirtier than
you think because so much of it is
invisible and off cited and yet we can
see now because of the carbon burn
especially but in many other ways
pollution and and strange chemicals and
pesticides included that we've been
putting out into the world faster than
the world can chew them up and and
restore them to more natural chemicals
and that's been going on for a long time
but the cleaner techs are already here
and getting better fast so what we would
mean is to find a way to pay ourselves
to install them as fast as possible to
swap out from a dirty fossil fuel tech
to a clean renewable technique einde
that would be consistently improving and
this comes back then again unfortunately
to the middle term which air look called
affluence and I don't like that because
Thoreau was affluent and he lived on
nothing so affluence is like a it's the
wrong word I called it appetite and I
think some other people called it
appetite so you could keep the a I think
we could just call it economics now and
call it the I pet formula because what
we really mean here is the economic
system is also a value system of how
much do we use and how do we pay
ourselves for what we do and so that is
where you get to this question of how
can we afford survival itself can we
afford to survive because it doesn't
pencil out the very commonly with
standard economics you will say to
someone well it would be way better if
we had solar power and clean energy
within 10 years and say well but but
it's so much more expensive or you could
say you know the Ogden Lalla aquifer is
being sucked up and used that's fossil
water when it goes a huge swath of the
central United States is going to be
without freshwater and so you could say
well we should immediately be making
gigantic clean energy desalination
plants all around the Gulf of Mexico or
what not
and then the answer is well but that's
too expensive and again there's that
fungibility there's that discounting of
the future in the future when when water
that isn't there becomes quite expensive
even though nonexistent then it will
actually pencil out to have desalination
so doing it now and ahead of time
that's why Frank Ackerman's book is
called a can we afford the future and
that's also why my old advisor Frederick
Jameson I think is the one who made up
this saying that it's easier to imagine
the end of the world than it is to
imagine the end of capitalism and this
has become one of the truisms of our
time one of the slogans of the
postmodern era and I'm thinking I want
to do what Fred would do is analyze this
phrase a little bit more and actually
look at the form of the content of this
phrase rather than the phrase itself if
you think of the end of the world as a
bad thing then okay it's easier to
imagine the bad thing and then the end
of capitalism if you agree with my
analysis of it then that would
indivisibly a so what the phrase is
really saying is that it's easier to
imagine bad things than it is to imagine
good things granted okay that's probably
true it's a matter of saying that it's
easier to feel your fears than it is to
feel your hopes and in many ways
especially in certain hours of the night
and fears are stronger than hopes and so
we are prey to them and the idea of
imagining a better future is may be
admirable or desirable and yet with
given the situation that we're in
imagining the end of the world is easier
than imagining the end of capitalism
imagining the bad is easier than
imagining the good but hope is tough and
it continues to persist in all
situations so we were going to hope our
way forward here as I continue to
attempt to find the lever that to to
Archimedes lever to change the situation
we got finance which is really fle
free-floating capital
system the market the laws that allow
capital to move around the world with
immense liquidity and power that can if
it wants the market can destroy nd
individuals currency by going in and
speculating on in a certain way as Soros
did with England as Europe is now doing
with Greece so there's free-floating
capital
there's also government's nation-states
and there's also simply people and I'm
thinking that they're in a kind of a
scissors rock paper configuration where
it isn't immediately obvious which one
manages to hammer the others but there's
a very strong case being made today
lazarettos governing by debt is a very
eye-opening book mauricio law Serato
that finance has whipped governments
that because governments all have huge
public debt that those debts those
government debts are to the banks to
finance which meanwhile has the freedom
to move anywhere it wants around the
world and there are no liquidity
controls on currencies so in there are
people who are saying that really it's
game over that that finance always ran
governments that governments were always
a false front and democracy was always a
kind of a kabuki for people to feel
comforted by this is a little too
cynical I think there's a better history
that can be written of the power of
democratic governments that come out of
the 18th century with quite a bit of
energy and I feel that after the
enclosure of the Commons people were so
emitter ated that democratic governments
were the virtual Commons
so the first virtuality is democratic
government in the 18th century but it's
a it's any time there's a commons
virtual or real
there's enclosure an enclosure can
always succeed by the immense the
universal solvent power of money and
it's universal fungibility on people's
brains but finance in its current
configuration prides itself on being
efficient and efficiency in economic
terms is a funny word it has to do with
you know just-in-time manufacturing of
not wasting it at any point along the
way and I will say this efficiency is
probably non-human but
a kind of an algorithm but definitely
it's not resilient a robust efficiency
is fragile so in this case finance is
never content to have only its own money
in the bank it loans it out it leverages
it so all of the big five banks and in
the United States and all big investment
institutions and firms are leveraged out
to to the point where only three to four
percent of the loans that they have
given out to the world
do they have in assets in hand back
there at the bank itself this was
revised by dodd-frank and by the Oxley
sarbanes after the 2008 crash and the
the Congress managed to regulate to the
point where they upped it up to like 5%
but then finance and the big banks have
wedged it back down there's a something
that Congress is mandated called this
systemically important financial
institution the SIF II which is really
means too big to fail with the idea that
you don't want to have institutions that
are too big to fail because then we have
to bail them out well both Westinghouse
and General Electric have gone to the
courts and argued that they are not too
big to fail that they're small enough
that they can fail and no one will be
harmed because they don't want to be put
under the regulations and restrictions
that are put on the big city and they
both won their cases I wish I could see
the transcript of their lawyers saying
to the government no we're not important
we're just we're really a tiny company
but in any case they are over leveraged
they're hanging out there over the abyss
and what they do is rely on people
people are illiquid in that you need a
job you need a house in you to pension
those are investments that last for
years you can't pull them and reinvest
them somewhere else at a higher rate of
return instantaneously or millions of
times a second like finance can do with
their liquidity so there are ways in
which it looks like the finance has the
upper hand and is like the rock smashing
the scissors or this scissors cutting
the paper because liquidity always beats
illiquidity and big always beat small
in these battles under the laws as we've
set them up but finance relies on
bundled payments of mortgages student
debt utility payments and indeed debts
of all kinds from responsible citizens
that come in on a monthly basis to the
big banks to the to the loan holders who
then take it
bungle it loan it back out leverage it
and they they are in essence
overextended so a moment comes when I
can see some of you are seeing my point
here the ultimate source of value the
ultimate securitization of all of these
loans are people themselves and the
payments that they've contracted to make
so there's a concept going around now
that sometimes called fiscal
non-compliance or strategic defaulting
or simply strike or odious debt personal
odious debt or the Jubilee or even the
idea that if everybody went to the bank
on the same day and asked for their
deposit back out the banks would not be
able to do it and they would crash on
the spot
in other words benas over leveraged as
they are in the crash of 2008 could be
artificially repeated by people deleted
on purpose so the subprime mortgage
crisis and hopefully you've all seen the
big short you know the story I can skip
that it was caused by people promising
to pay debts that they didn't have the
money to pay and so when time went on
they all crashed at the same time and
the whole system came down that that can
happen again any time the the way the
capitalism works is permanent growth
there'll be another bubble there'll be
another crash but in this case people
could actually cause the crash on
purpose
July 4th 2019 you pick your date you
have Independence Day whatever you know
not paying your mortgage is possibly
going to be a popular move there would
be this particular kind of surveillance
everybody is all freaked out about
surveillance the government is watching
you at all times it's big brother-ish
blah blah blah everybody complains on
this on Facebook and on their Twitter so
it's a little bit bizarre but say it's a
real complaint but
here's the surveillance accounts your
credit rating that's surveillance by
Finance of you so if we were to have
this moment of strategic defaulting
fiscal non-compliance to bring the banks
down a afterwards we would have to
figure forgive ourselves by way of
Congress this odious debt and
everybody's credit rating would have to
reflect that their their credit rating
for that particular day was a matter of
free speech and political action and
therefore forgivable and or on the other
hand you could just say that after that
happens you get retroactive debt
restructuring and we go back to the
table and renegotiate with the banks
what's going on but but okay we bring
down the banks this is like bringing
down the your mountaineering partner on
the big face you don't you know you're
tied to them you don't really want to
bring them down because then you oh my
god I'm tied to them we're both going
down this is what is happening in 2008
so there needs to be another part of the
plan in place which simply is a
government that understands that at that
point the basket for saving the finance
climber that you have suddenly clipped
their belay and they're falling the the
basket is this you nationalize them we
nationalize GM in 2008 it worked they
paid us back we saved their ass the real
economy needed saving finance we paid
off we bailed out at 100 cents on the
dollar to the tune of somewhere between
seven trillion and thirteen trillion
dollars I've heard both figures Friday
you see I heard 13 trillion by a very
distinguished economic historian this is
because the quantitative easing as well
as the original bailout so that amount
of money is a kind of amazing act but
this time if we've crashed the bank or
if they happen to blow a bubble on their
own either way we have to at that point
say yes we'll bail you out but now we
own you and so now we own you means the
government is the board of directors
that we began to set regulations we
begin to determine loans it would be
like the Federal Credit Union all of
these things have their precedence in
earlier public utility district type
moves
so at that point with the government
taking over it would run the loan
strategies the repayment way rates and
to the extent that it profited the
profits would just go into the Treasury
you combine that with the obvious carbon
tax that we need to put on which is not
a tax but it's paying the true cost we
need to reconnect
what he suggested two years ago which is
that you don't just have a progressive
tax on income because people who are
wealthy enough can hide their income in
another country or under the rug or in
future what investments in the future so
income you can hide capital assets a
progressive tax sharply progressive tax
on capital assets is such a game-changer
such a paradigm buster that when the
Wall Street Journal and The Economist
reviewed picket East book and they got
to this last chapter they said oh well
but that would never work because and
then there 500-word article ran out and
they got to stop at that point they
never said why because there is no why
because it would work and it would be an
incredibly powerful tool in terms of the
horizontal ization of human wealth to
more of the population there's hardly a
better suggestion and Piketty spoke may
have been as some people said you know
eleven chapters of Marxism followed by
one chapter of Keynesian reform
suggestions but I'm you know I'm non
Keynesian myself I think we're in a
Keynesian world and I think many people
who do the eleven chapters of Marxian
analysis would then like to contribute
something useful that could be done
right now in the world and a tax
structure is not the most radical
suggestion it's already been done before
so that would create a government
surplus instead of government being in
debt to finance forever in eternity and
therefore under the thumb of finance
government would be having a surplus
would be in control of finance and it
would have flipped the scissors rock
paper as to who controls who at that
point paper would control government
people would control governments
governments would control finance
finance would work for the people you
would have the the way the system needed
to work now what would we do with that
money
health care of course free public
education of course through college why
not and then also fuller
employment because full employment is
another gigantic paradigm Buster for
capitalism
we have 5.4 percent minimum unemployment
if it goes below that the markets
depressed and you you want Labor wage
pressure wage pressure is pressure on
human beings lives and minds in order to
keep them willing to work for depressed
wages so that profits will be better
once again it's going back to that one
algorithm so what you would want at that
point with full employment if you could
always get a good living wage job from
the government then private industries
that existed which would be on the
margin I would call it would have to
compete by giving a living wage
themselves that everybody would have one
along with Social Security so what would
everybody do well there there's no this
idea that automation is going to get rid
of jobs is a very silly bad science
fiction story it's not right it's not
going to be that way many things take
the human touch taking care of young
people take care of old people taking
care of sick people and also landscape
restoration that's the environmental
work of this project of a government
that's in control of the the humans /
biosphere future because the two are
tied together would be an enormous
amount of infrastructure changes and
landscape restoration in general to get
us a planet where we're not using up you
know the biosphere is regenerative
possibilities by August of every year
which is what we're doing now but are in
balance with the biosphere properly so
at that point that's my definition of
post capitalism and I don't want to put
any other name on it than that and in
fact if you'd like to say but it's still
capitalism there will still be capital
there still be a kind of a regulated
market that's fine by me
it's not about names it's about function
and survivability about robustness and
resilience in facing the climate change
that has already baked in so it doesn't
matter
and at first axiom if more is better is
the wrong one what's the right one
probably something like Aldo Leopold
what's good is what's good for the land
you unpack that you find the derivatives
of that one if it's good for the land
it's going to be good for people
eventually another one might be the
greatest good for the greatest number
if this is Bentham and you know John
Stuart Mill the idea would be that the
greatest number includes the biosphere
itself all the living creatures the
bacteria the plants the animals
especially the other mammals that are so
endangered the the greatest good for the
greatest number is a good rubric and so
is what's good is what's good for the
land more is better is not a good rubric
and we're going to have to change it but
in detail and in general as a kind of a
value system so at that point capitalism
as we know it now will be a residual in
the system in the residual emergent idea
of Raymond Williams and as residual you
could apply it to the toys and the games
and to tourism
if the necessities are socialized like
food water shelter clothing healthcare
education all those socialized and
belonging to all as this is public
utilities then you could still say I
want an iPhone 12 more than an iPhone 11
and there could still be companies
making a profit it might cost you
realistically you know twenty five
thousand dollars for your iPhone rather
than a thousand if you want to pay the
true cost of it but some people might
want to do that and some people might
afford it enough to be able to do it
they may you would certainly take better
care of your phone your car your goods
in general so this is the this is the
notion of capitalism on the margin
regulated market and then this is I want
to end with the greatest American
science fiction short story you will
recognize it that government of the
people by the people and for the people
shall not perish from this earth it's
the shall not that's a future imperative
it makes it a science fiction story it's
not a given
we are not it's not a legacy thing it's
a perpetual battlefield government of by
and for the people right now is
endangered as you know it's it's heavily
under threat because financed thinking
everything's fungible to everything else
is thinking well we can buy the
government's too so the struggle over
government is going on and this
injunction by this command by Lincoln at
Gettysburg itself is a very important
reminder it's a science it's a utopian
science fiction story in effect because
democracy is not natural nor is it easy
it's
more complicated than anything else so
this is this is the science fiction
story to end with and I just hit 35
minutes on the market Wow grab these
things I've got a couple questions I
expect you've got some questions so let
me do my two quickly and then we'll get
to discussion
go go go go hang on to that drink if you
want yeah no I need alcohol now give me
a little more on the subtitle how
climate will evolve governmental
societies climate you see is in this
century of forcing mechanism I guess for
what you're talking about right is that
play out because the claimant carbon tax
I got what else
well sea-level rise once we get past the
tipping point of a certain tipping
points then we can't do anything about
it
there will be unstoppable will be in
coping mode so and it's it's exactly the
capitalist system that has got us TD
around them brink through its own
successes I mean it's again it's
accidental it's successful it is not
villainous or criminal and it's not
being cheated on or tweat so I'm
thinking that when people realize that
the biosphere itself is in danger and
that we're in danger of creating the
sixth great mass extinction event so we
got the Anthropocene we've got the five
great mass extinction events and now
we're starting the sixth one that this
will force the action on what might have
taken centuries otherwise so we've had
climate change going on for a while you
see science of this kind of forcing
happening yes I guess we right now we
have a Democratic Socialist running for
president this is not just a miseration
and the 1% I sort of assumed you were
not supporting Donald Trump in this
Donald's right well this is the this is
again of forcing action I mean the the
reactions to this kind of stress will be
intense and crazy across the board and
you know that I want to also add very
quickly that if women's rights are a
world issue for the environment and for
justice that we also have a candidate
running this election that has done more
for women's rights institutionally than
almost any other human in the history of
the human race which is Hillary Clinton
so I personally would love to see them
just fuse like you guys here can
probably do this right you just kind of
make them into one candidate but I I
would I would want to I want to add that
about Hillary because I can see that
she's gonna be facing a tremendous
amount of unwarranted criticisms you're
here I suppose another politically
related question is you just got the
robert heinlein yes I sense a little
irony there robert heinlein probably
twisted more adolescent minds into
libertarian approach to life than
anybody well now yeah that's true but
I'm trying to cut him some slack and
there's reason there's good ways to do
it when he was young and living in Los
Angeles he was known as crazy Bob
Heinlein and he believed in Lion
marriages nudity utopia for everyone and
he was very much at odds with and even
in fist fights with l ron Hubbard
another colleague of his time in that
yeah wait come on why so I hear it's a
common story the Los Angeles science
fiction Society had at the same time
online Hubbard Ray Bradbury and it was a
vibrant place and crazy Bob at that
point was I would say ideologically
polymorphous later on as happens to so
many of us he got in his old age quite
conservative and crusty considering that
the best form of human government would
be the hooter I'm not sure about that
well when you came along with the Mars
trilogy there were a couple things that
were unique at the time one was Mars was
not hip then it's insanely hip now and
you were writing a pretty leftist
economic model on to basically how the
geoengineering the terraforming of Mars
wouldn't play out is that accurate yeah
yeah that's right and in your mind where
you're doing that is that's how you
could realistically imagine Mars
actually being terraformed or this was
it last a chance of a platform to play
out some of your leftist fantasies well
maybe more the latter when I was writing
the Mars books it was the Viking data
the Viking data came in in 76 and they
gave us a Mars that was a million times
more detailed than what we had before
that mariner and Viking it took a while
to assimilate for science fiction
writers and say well what have we got
here and then it was Sagan and his crowd
that said if you were interested in
terraforming and wanted to plan it to do
it Mars is as good as it gets
it'll never find a place that is more
close to being terraformable and they
began to model it so I was the lucky
recipient of that when I began to write
novels and I saw that Mars would be a
great place to backpack and it resembled
the High Sierra which it didn't but in
green Mars and blue Mars it does it was
yeah it goes like from the Ruby region
Nevada to the Sierra to the Coastal
Range over the trilogy it was something
I wanted to do and then the leftist
ideas is just my my hippy California
Gary Snyder New Age Buddhist you know
you know the drill here I am Garrett is
a red diaper baby he grew up with it did
you no no I grew up in Orange County - a
blue diaper baby
whatever it was not a political
household it was a technical and pseudo
a political household pseudo a political
household well I I think that the
American technical class would say
happens too often that well I'm just
into technical stuff I transcend
politics or politics is the
grubby stuff and sciences the clean
stuff and they try to make an artificial
distinction between the two
so are you basically turning against
feather and somebody get to you with a
more interesting and persuasive frame it
was a combination of Schneider Fredric
Jameson
Ursula Quinn and a science fiction
community itself I was very lucky in my
teachers all three of those were
teachers of mine at different times of
my life
Jameson was my thesis advisor and he
told me to write about philip k dick the
greatest living American writer at which
my jaw dropped I had only read galactic
pot healer and I was looking at this
professor thinking you've got to be
kidding but I went ahead and I read Phil
dick on on Fred Jameson's behalf and
then Gary was teaching poetry at Davis
when I was there and so I took classes
from him and Ursula came down to UCSD
and taught a science fiction writing at
UCSD so I'm thinking just yet they tell
you have fun back with the beige arm go
ahead and stand up and and say your name
that'll help us all get him here you
yeah yeah so um I'm deep into a row
right now I'm deep into reading Aurora
right now and it's maybe you know I've
read a couple other books of yours in
the past one of my questions is you
never seek out genetic modification as a
solution to the problems that you've
created for your books can you talk a
little bit more about that this is a
biology yeah you know in until the
CRISPR technology came along just last
month or so I felt like the solutions
need to be imagined at the macro scale
of I I think that it's all too
complicated and we don't know enough yet
to propose genetic engineering solutions
to most problems now I used to say that
also about artificial intelligence but
things have been changing so quickly
recently that as painful as it is I've
had to make some reconsiderations say a
little bit about what you're
chattering about AI since that is a
topic of much discussion and dispute
well I think AI is that we mistake it
for the science fiction dream of it and
I think artificial intelligence is
really our way of saying either science
or capitalism or some global system
beyond our understanding that seems to
have taken over history itself and so I
want to propose that when we talk about
AI we're talking about science and we're
imagining it as Big Brother as a how in
2001 a Space Odyssey who will out of a
mistaken good intentions kill us all but
in fact it's always under our control
it's mainly just really fast processing
and until I began to listen to people
done at Google talking about quantum
computing I thought it's just like a
giant adding machine and so what it's
still history is still in human hands
because the machines don't have
intention will consciousness etc now if
if quantum computing succeeds which is
we don't know because we don't know if
we can stabilize the qubits but if we
can stabilize qubits and they begin and
the algorithms written for them are
clever enough we might get some really
fast computers and then you ask them are
you conscious and they're gonna say I
don't know because I don't know what
consciousness is but let me think about
it and I'm thinking you know maybe a
trillion times faster than you are so
whatever's going on let's call it
consciousness and this is the narrator
of Aurora a machine that probably is not
conscious like we are but when the
processing speeds get that fast we are
very the Turing test is a very low bar
we're easily fools but like like your
iPhone your thinking is conscious you
know just because it answers your
question so the Turing test is not the
big test here here I would say I'll add
something on quantum computing which is
that in August one of the seminars about
long-term thinking we have coming as
from Seth Lloyd and he's one of the
pioneers of quantum computing and his
talk is called quantum computing reality
in the sense that he's been with it long
enough he's got perspective on it and
the hype and the anti hype all right
hopefully he'll be able to lead us into
it's actually happening and when I've
heard him recently just chatting about
it frankly more is happening that I
thought mm-hmm
but it's incremental and you know then
you get a sense of what's the rate of
the incremental improvement and what
things happen to various stages that's
what he'll talk about and then all of
this will be trying to keep up with it
well the questions thoughts right here
speak up stand up speak up my name is
Carter Brooks
I appreciate very much your sort of
allusions to the fact that what we have
is capitalism right now sort of no one's
fault in a way that it sort of is
naturally emerges that way and so my
question is to sort of expand on that a
little bit one of the pet descriptions I
use of the situation we're in is that we
have a civilizational organism that's
metabolizing the stored energy the
planet so it's like having a big open
bank vault you know or even earlier
before we sort of tap that we certainly
had big open resources so so in that
context modern capitalism those we have
it I see is something that sort of
naturally emerges out of that situation
not from a sort of nefarious intense or
etc and I'm wondering whether you have
any thoughts about that yeah thank you
um there's a I it's very important I
think to read or at least read abstracts
the describing the work of Giovanni
Arrighi
who is a historian of capitalism that it
began in Genoa and and it's a
marshalling of external resources that
can be exploited and and manufactured
and sold and so it goes through a stage
of exploration and then of
industrialization and then a
financialization when it taps out its
resources and he has a history of
capitalism and Genoa Holland Britain USA
and the point at the end is that there's
not a next place to expand into it and
this is one description of the crisis
that we're in now the environmental
crisis the financial crisis are there's
not a next stage to do capitalist growth
into which was always a bit rapacious to
local populations and to labor all along
it was extractive exploitative and and
accumulative
in ways that weren't fair to the workers
that actually do
to work so it's never been a just system
but it was never been on purpose
designed in a villainous way it's just
people protecting their own situation
now once we're in this situation the
growth would have to be in terms of
improvement or involution space won't
work it doesn't pencil out the gravity
will keep space from working and there's
nothing out there that we don't already
have here that we actually need so I
mean in the science fiction community
they would say well of course the next
stage is the solar system in the next
stage after that is the Milky Way and
bla bla bla no I always argue against
that as being physically impossible so
we are in a fix where we need a change
and this is why I think we've got this
moment the the long now we also I hear
people talking about the long emergency
although the long emergency kind of
cute' is not as long as the long now the
long emergency might be a century or two
where we in this next century or two we
have to get into a balance with the
biosphere as a civilization that's a
kind of an emergency okay yeah I just
wanted to ask a bit more about your
vision for the future and how technology
could play a role in reducing carbon
emissions when in a state-controlled
system you you painted this portrait of
you know the state takes control of the
banks and and then you know implement
some type of carbon tax and that leads
to a benevolent system but but we do
have a current example of a state
controlled economy that's trying very
hard to make progress on environmental
concerns which is China and I was an
environmental journalist in China for
years and saw firsthand how that those
efforts often failed I mean state
controlled oil companies like Sinopec
and and PetroChina would refuse to
upgrade their refineries even though
they were ordered to and state orders to
install wind turbines would result in
wind turbines in the ground but they
weren't connected to anything there was
just failure after a failure of that
system so I just wanted you to explain a
little more about how your vision would
work
sure but now let's let's say China is an
aberration and a strange example because
they got a billion people on a land
surface the size of the United
states where a lot of that land is
unusable desert like here and that what
they first wanted was poverty reduction
in the initial Chinese effort was first
to get themselves out from under the
imperialist Western crushing of their
culture and then to get on to a quickly
industrialized basis so they went
through the kind of Stalinist Maoist
moment that was a moment of the extreme
suffering and now it's said that 200
engineers around the country but as
you're pointing out that isn't really
possible with a billion people because
orders go down and then they filter out
into the sand and they disappear better
example would be Cuba if you have an XY
graph that talks about quality of life
and the other factor is impact on the
environment all of the countries go from
well we don't have much impact on
environment but we have very poor
quality of life and the graph moves up
like that
the more quality of life the more impact
on the environment and then there's this
one aberration it's it's out there like
a an amazing factoid which is cubed so
now I don't know if the whole world
immediately went to Cuba's rules we
would be better off I don't know if
that's true or not but I proposed it
because of the data let's say if the
entire world ran by Denmark's rules we
would be better off so there you got
social democracy rather than some
bizarre pressured form of socialism and
communism social democracy I think so so
you go in terms of where we are now in
neoliberal capitalism where capital
itself has no brain except it's just
profit it will eat up the world in the
same way that the Chinese did in their
attempt to improve their people maybe
even worse so what you need is anti
austerity Keynesianism social democracy
and then post capitalism of some kind of
definition and I'm saying the state is
often mythologized
on the left the right the center as a
big bad beast and I'm saying let's call
the state government let's say we're in
charge of it and change the terms and
see if we get a better feeling about
who's the next person for the Mike
okay it kind of related to what you were
just saying you know we often criticize
the revolving door between banks and
government as it is how how do you when
the regulated and the regulators are the
same people in a state controlled
banking system how do you how do you
control corruption when you know how do
you get stopped those people from paying
themselves well I guess what you would
do is just say that people get a good
salary for a good day's work and then
take out bonuses and corruption is a
problem but then what you need is the
the General Accounting Office the GAO is
very much more important federal agency
than is usually given credit for
we have checks and balances within the
federal government system that went
allowed to work do a an okay job with
with that said you know power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
there's that's a pretty good descriptor
of humanity's engagements with itself so
you would have to try to be careful but
I would rather have a government elected
democratic government in control of
Finance than finance in control of
government and the 2008 situation the
the head of the the chief of the Federal
Reserve and the Secretary of Treasury
and the assistant secretary Treasury
were all goldman sachs veterans and they
were thinking like a bank so there's a
great book thinking like a state
james-scott thinking like a bank you
know it's another kind of states that
can be mythologized in the same way and
so they they bailed out the banks rather
than the people so the next bailout
that's why I'm saying nationalization is
the next bailout you bailout the people
rather than the banks and see what
happens it will not be the in solution
because success is failure this is one
of those troubling phrases of my teacher
Fred Jameson its dialectical which means
that you can't understand it you know
but success is failure
so say you you get rid of infectious
diseases and suddenly the infant
mortality rate drops like a stone and
suddenly the population rate rises to
right now so you had a success
it turned into a failure or it turn into
the next problem let's say so when I
propose a solution
and believe me all I'm trying to say is
let's try these things out and then
struggle on from there yeah my version
of that is Tennessee is become poisoned
next person with mic my name is Georgia
you're standing so people can see you I
had hoped to return to the I pet formula
three three or arguably I'd propose that
some of what happens in they II say how
much appetite or how much consumption is
allowed or occurs has to do not just
with the state of the tea technology but
with the kind of futures market on
technologies or science fictional
understandings of them and if that's
true I wonder if some of the interests
you mentioned at the beginning of your
talk might seem manipulating that
futures market and over selling certain
technologies say carbon capture and
sequestration and CDR solar radiation
management geoengineering as a way of um
stranding some of their assets do you
think that's plausible and if so how do
you think it might play out well if I
understand you I'm thinking that the
what you want in futures markets is to
buy options and and and essentially it
began as insurance if things go wrong
with this investment by something that
happens in the future can i hedge so you
head yourself against bad futures by
doing what's resilient a robust so the
idea of the hedge is a strong one until
it turns into an excuse for casino
gambling it's john Lanchester that said
there's many words in economics that now
mean exactly the opposite of what they
originally meant so when you go to a
hedge fund now and means crazy gambling
rather than insurance against things
going wrong these things happen it's
also true that if capitalism is
absolutely tapped out the world as a
place to get a maximum rate of return
they dive into your unconscious minds
that's the entertainment industry but
they also dive into the future so that's
debt and mortgage so that they are
attempting to buy the future itself the
system buys the future so I I think
futures markets is one of those terms
that gives me a quiver of oh my god how
dangerous like nitroglycerine or what
Warren Buffett called you know weapons
of mass fiscal destruction
and but nevertheless we do have to plan
a future and that that's one of the
tools for it so I think what you need is
fiscally educated people who know about
derivatives and futures markets and and
puts and calls and options in general
going to work on this as a can we afford
the future type problem where you have a
very low discount rate on the future and
try to build a livable future out of it
you know financially as well as
ethically let me come to the last
question which relates in a way and
you're a futures market here in the
sense of writing futures it's true and
one we all wonder what's in the near
future for you what are you working on
what books are coming out what's what's
next room Stan well I have a I have
given you the plot of my next book
tonight as you may have guessed and the
that's Wall Street in the foreground
there so you see the setting a local
habitation and a name for a story that
you might call utopia against finance
but it really it's called New York 21:40
and the sea-level rise is approximately
50 feet which I thought was quite
radical until I read the latest paper by
James Hansen at which point it seemed
like James Hansen was just trying to
make my novel look more plausible than
it did before
and it doesn't stop at 50 feet well it
just depends on it certainly doesn't
have to stop at 50 feet if all the ice
on the planet melted it would be 270
feet we'd be under water here I think we
definitely might be
so it's just I forgot where we were is
this a tall Venice yes I call it the
super Venice and I'm saying that if even
if lower Manhattan goes under between
materials science and people's
stubbornness to stay in you know the Big
Apple that people will cope and there
will be waterproofing and there will be
gondolas and you know super Venice fun
novel singing gondolier I can't wait
yeah what's this
it's called New York 21:40 which reminds
you to seize the Blenheim aha Karpin
Millennium indeed thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you all just a
last couple reminders
we have borderlands books who as many of
you know as the wonderful cinderella
story of the sci-fi book store that was
rejuvenated by san francisco and is here
selling all of well many of Stan's books
so please buy them he's going to hang
out here and sign several of them and if
you can't help us move the chairs to the
wall that would be great don't try and
pick up more than one chair just pick up
your one chair move it to the wall thank
you very much
[Music]
you